hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
yes it's whatever episode it is of
congratulations
congratulations who knows
wearing it nice got the nice shirt from
advisory board crystals
just killing it got buttoned up
you know what i mean looks good with the
gray and my beard forget it super casual
but also knows what he's doing you know
what i mean
um
i uh let's get it out the way we got
dates coming up in brea california i am
on tourish kind of um brea california
and irvine california and we are uh i'm
expanding after that i'm expanding after
that but right now i'm doing a little
bit of some local gigs crystallia.com
brea is soon that may be sold out i just
added a show so go check it out
crystalia.com if you're in southern
california in brea or irvine come check
it out um so that's what's up i'm doing
the crystallia and friends and uh we've
been having a good time uh we did uh
what do you call it oxnard and san diego
actually
uh before i get into that let me say uh
if you also go to my website we re-upped
on all the life rips tie-dyed [ __ ] i i
it keeps selling out guys you guys still
want it so i'm still re-upping it um so
it's up there and we got all the other
two separate colorways that are up and
that's the last restock that's gonna be
for that um but there is new merch and
the new hot [ __ ]
uh that we uh that we as a cult
need to [ __ ] share with the world
dude don't push me dude don't push me
it's got that [ __ ] it's a it's an
homage to right chris don't push me dude
work with me but we've got the [ __ ]
eagle on there and it says don't push me
and we've got a hat with those [ __ ]
tassels that makes it look like you're
in the army or the navy or some [ __ ] and
it's just really [ __ ] so check that out
chris leah.com and that shit's gonna fly
off the shelves like the eagle on its
chest man
you got to let them know dude whatever's
going on in your life don't push me dude
i'm at a certain spot
not today
this is not the day right
stand your stand for yourself right
um so uh rep that and let them know dude
that's gonna fly i'm telling you uh
crystalia.com so that's what's up and uh
that's what's been uh going on merch
wise and then also come see me in brea
or irvine chrisleya.com go to
crusadia.com honestly have a great time
dude it's basically the metaverse just
go there
um and uh
and that's it we were in san diego this
past um
weekend actually this will be it'll be
two weekends ago now um and it was let
me tell you something man
i think it was like episode 40 something
i was talking about how much san diego
sucked
and because i went there and whenever i
perform there it's always like these
people that think that they're [ __ ]
better than you and [ __ ] it's like a lot
of whites with like [ __ ]
uh
like
like doc like dockers on and [ __ ]
and they're they're the they're they're
like offended for minorities when you
say a joke about minorities like those
kinds of guys but also man
i didn't realize how [ __ ] republican
san diego was also and they those
audiences
[ __ ] rip man
and so i realized that the only time the
only reason why i didn't like playing uh
san diego is because their venues i was
at were just [ __ ]
horrible
i played house of blues which is a
[ __ ] music venue i mean last time i
went to house of blues by my by myself
was when i was [ __ ] 20 years old i
went to go see bus to rhymes
so it's like what the [ __ ] is what am i
doing what am i doing
you know playing it at a at a a venue
that buster
you know
so uh i played the uh the laugh factory
down there which uh i wanted to just you
know work out my my uh material and [ __ ]
and that club down there is [ __ ]
awesome man and we had a blast dude
i took the new car down there bloody
interior oh [ __ ]
i took the boss mobile down there oh
[ __ ]
i took my [ __ ] camera man oh dude i
look back it was like he was [ __ ]
four rows back oh
god
right birds flew over and they were the
only ones who could see the bloody guts
because the windows were
tinted oh god i know
and it's a bit matte white but is it
semi-mad oh he just did it a little bit
right he just did it a little bit okay
he took the badges off the back
it's a boss nobody needs to know so um
so yeah i do
oh my god man so i [ __ ] we took the
bus my bill down there you still don't
know what it is dude he's keeping it a
mystery my babies that's what he's doing
he's mysterious
oh god he's mysterious just [ __ ]
bathing in that blood on the inside
so um
anyway dude uh
oh god it's like [ __ ] he's got the
kid in the car too it's like the [ __ ]
last episode of the first season in
dexter and what the [ __ ] is going on so
he um so anyway we went down to san
diego and we had a good time and uh it
was great dude
i just [ __ ] san diego was absolutely
it was great the crowds were so good man
they were just [ __ ]
we got the with chris video out now san
diego you can go check it out uh it's on
my other youtube channel more crystal
there you go subscribe and like to that
and while you're at subscribing like to
this and make friends in the comments
dude it helps that algorithm and you
know if you want your boy to keep going
on stuff like king of the sting and
fight companion and all the other
podcasts saying you need to understand
he provides a bump and the only thing
that helps that is if we activate that
algorithm
keep the algorithm out doing
calisthenics
[Music]
so um
so yeah dude
um
wow i've said absolutely [ __ ] nothing
in the first five minutes of this
podcast all good that's what we do dude
cause we're roaring you wanna go get
info you want to go get boring as [ __ ]
info go listen to [ __ ] npr man this
is where we come we hang out if it was
the [ __ ] in 1999 people would say we
chillax but i never said that
i say we relax and we chill we we we
respect both of those words we don't say
[ __ ] i'm not a guy who does you know
takes the two words and put them
together like fantabulous that's such a
like a like a a a portly white woman
thing to do oh it's fantabulous you know
what i mean like a pear-shaped white
woman loves combining words but your boy
gives the words talking about the guy
who [ __ ] abbreviates the most words
on the planet but anyway dude i respect
the words i need to respect is what i'm
trying to say
so i got to [ __ ] so we were in san
diego and it was beautiful man we got
some coffee people wanted to take
pictures i saw a bunch of people dressed
in a banana and banana outfits don't
even i don't even understand but dude
the homeless problem in la if you think
the homeless problem well the homeless
problem in downtown is probably way
worse but dude in san diego it's [ __ ]
forget it dude
so many homeless people it's sad as [ __ ]
it's sad [ __ ] man
they gotta figure that out just kind of
for everyone for the homeless people but
also for the not homeless people
there was a homeless guy i was trying to
get pizza and he was just like
dude i don't even know like he was just
he came up to me and he was like hey
what's up i thought he was a crazy
homeless dude and he was he was like
what you need man my family owns this
place and i'm like oh [ __ ] wow no it's
okay man don't worry about it he's like
what'd you need a family owns this place
and i pulled i i had to like be like yo
man it's okay i hear you you got to back
up though a little bit and i kind of
like gently touched his you know his
chest and just kind of you got to got to
back up a little bit he's like what you
need you need to water some and i'm like
i i don't know man we're all good let me
just order the pizza and i ordered the
pizza and then he was like all right
chris you take care i was like oh he's
got a home
he knows who i am
am i so famous that [ __ ] homeless
people know who i am
i don't i don't think i am i'm genuinely
asking because that's like elite level
fame
if you got dudes with like
frayed jeans on walking around with
dirty feet and they're like hey it's you
then you made it dude
right
so i didn't really understand what i
mean maybe his family did own it he also
had a really weird expensive [ __ ]
hoodie on can't remember what it was but
maybe he was just a crazy owner
oh no show me love up in the club
um
so yeah uh san diego was was was nice as
[ __ ] stayed at the [ __ ] andaz had a
good stay
got four rooms probably won't get him
reimbursed from that from the [ __ ]
laugh factory owner all good but um
yeah uh
i drew i drove the car today i was gonna
go meet my son um and kristen at the
park
and
[ __ ] took the [ __ ] new car out
right the new car out wanted to get the
luxurious
boss mobile just out for the day to go
meet my son
and all of a sudden ding ding now
remember when i got the lemon i already
have the car that's the lemon i got a
lemon i fixed it the car's not a lemon
anymore okay we took it in for like two
weeks they redid the whole shits
and uh
so now that car works i got the other
you know [ __ ]
and all of a sudden dang ding the back
left tire
it's at 11.
it's not even at like [ __ ] 20 you
know how it's like if it's at 26 you're
like oh [ __ ] gotta fill it up
this [ __ ] should be at 47. it's at 11.
it's got 11 pieces of air in it you know
i don't know what the thing is it should
have 47 pieces of [ __ ] air in it
and it's got 11 pieces of air in it dude
it's missing 36 pieces of air
so i'm like well [ __ ] [ __ ] man
and i go i i look to my [ __ ] my
assistant and and dude she's good she's
like pull over i'll check it she knows a
lot about cars she's like pull over i'll
check it
and we look and we check it and she's
like yeah it looks a little low but the
tires also you know what i mean how can
you tell if your tires are low if you
got that low pro anyway right
i mean my tires are low pro anyway what
am i going to be rolling around on
knobbies dude what am i in a [ __ ]
what am i in a [ __ ] rav4 this shit's
so low pro my tires got sunglasses on
and high collars
you got the neighbors calling about my
tires
hey i see something out there but oh
maybe i didn't
my tires are crazy
okay so it's like okay is it is it
[ __ ]
low or not i don't know but then we go
hold on a second and we hear
and we go wait a second we get closer
and then we feel
and it's a [ __ ] not a slow leak dude
there's a nail in there the [ __ ] is
coming out
holy i mean dude it's so it's
so we're like we got what do we do she's
like we should call triple a i was like
let's just drive to the [ __ ] place we
can make it and she's like okay and we
do it and we roll down there and we get
to the [ __ ] place and it's going ten
nine and i'm gonna be like we're gonna
start sparking the rims
this is just today so i get to the
[ __ ] place she's like this place is
good i know it she knows a lot about
cars so we get to the place some dude 21
years old 23 years old some [ __ ] like
that he's just like hey
you know he had that face on he had that
face on
it that was like
oh
what [ __ ] man i was just gonna go do
something else you know
hey and my [ __ ] uh assistant just
says what are you doing right now dude
the way she said it
his whole [ __ ] just dropped and he just
gave up and he was like i was just gonna
go eat lunch uh what is it and she she
was like oh we got a leak i was like we
got a leak here dude can you fix it and
he was like uh yeah sure dude
conversational tko man she just put him
to sleep with that convo just already
like like my uncle told me once he was
like dude if anyone ever wants to fight
you or they're following you or you
think something's going down approach
them and just be like what's up dude
what's going on it throws them off
now my uncle's a little bit of an insane
person he's also 350 pounds and is a
black belt and [ __ ] karate but still
though
you know what i mean you gotta like it's
like the end of eight mile where you're
like yeah you [ __ ] my girl and you
ruined my life what are you gonna say
now
and then the guy's like
like [ __ ] colin firth in
just stutterville right whatever that
movie is called stutterville king speech
and um
so i basically he's like sure i'll do it
and he does it and my car is parked in
like a situation
where it's like kind of blocking
the place to get into the to the
uh whatever the garage right
so this other porsche cayenne pulls up
and it's like kind of a it's a porsche
cayenne but also like
fix it like it's got [ __ ] all [ __ ] up
with it the tires are so bald and this
dude pulls up
and he said and and he and the and the
guy
who's working there says oh can you just
pull in and my car is a little bit kind
of in the way
and i feel bad about it
so the guy goes to move past my car into
the garage in the cayenne
and he says uh he's like this you know
young black dude and he says uh
and and he's like
um and he says to me
uh
because i'm looking make sure he's good
and also i don't want him to hit my car
and he's like i can see man i can see
i can see man don't trip
and i was like oh yeah that's what i
said i could see man don't trip
and he pulled in and i was like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
know and then i went into this just
and by the way it was so like i knew i
was like
when he parked i knew when he got out i
was like i bet he has [ __ ] slides on
got out sure enough had slides on i knew
it dude i'm [ __ ] that doesn't mean
anything but i'm [ __ ] sherlock holmes
when it doesn't matter
and um
and so
like sherlock holmes is figuring out
murders but i'm like i bet this guy's
got [ __ ] slides on and i know that
and then so maybe i'm like sherlock
holmes's assistant but anyway
um
so he gets out and and while the guy was
jacking up my tire do you guys ever do
this like i was like just in a vivid
daydream
imagining
like if this guy said something else or
like
if he tripped or like i was imagining
like if he tripped or if he asked hey
where's the bathroom and then the guy
points to it and it says bathroom above
the door for me to i wanted so badly
something like that to happen so i could
be like oh [ __ ] man sorry i thought you
could see it
oh i'm sorry man i thought you might see
it
don't trip
and that didn't happen but in my head
and my my heart i was getting so angry
about it and i'm like if this [ __ ]
happens dude i'm um i'm ready
and then while i was deep in that vivid
imagination and that daydream the guy
just goes it's 25 dollars to pat your
car and i was about to retire and i was
like oh okay
and then and then my assistant was like
here's the here's the thing for the
wheel to undo the wheel and then let's
get the tire p uh how many tire p pieces
it we needs it's on the inside of the
door and the guy's like well she knows a
lot about cars i was like yeah bro
that's like fast and furious man she's
like michelle rodriguez
anyway man it all worked out okay my
tires patched
and you know i survived a near-death
experience
because of the nail and also because the
guy almost [ __ ]
you know he almost got into it with me i
see it man don't trip okay cool
sounds good
bro speaking of not tripping this is
unreal
i don't like rick ross it's like i think
rick ross is at the level where it's
like
you made a lot of music and like he was
the [ __ ] hot [ __ ] and now he he
obviously makes a lot of money and it
makes a lot of music but he's not like
the hot [ __ ] anymore like this is the
most [ __ ] this is an instagram video
he put on this is here this let's just
play that music back there
i told myself rosie when you get in the
position i want somebody to be at my
house at certain times just to play the
harp okay just to play the piano okay
and at this particular time i had the
money to pay nobody to come do that for
me which i really meant and told myself
i meant so what i did was because i was
getting some money i went and bought the
piano that played itself
and then he shows a piano that plays
itself
i mean
uh
sir
lonely
also show the cam show the piano closer
so far away
i bought the piano that played itself
like this guy are you [ __ ] 11
like that's not even like those have
they've been around since [ __ ] bar
fights and saloons
like that's not that impressive every
piano has a play itself mode
i bought the piano that plays itself
also brag about the brag when it happens
when i was younger i said i wanted to
have somebody play the piano for me and
at this particular moment
dude rappers are always saying moments
like particular moment like just say
moment
you know this particular moment
me personally my particular moment
what had happened was always adding
extra words just say what happened what
had happened in this particular moment
for me personally it's like how many
[ __ ] words are you gonna use guy
when i was younger
i wanted to make i wanted to have a god
play the piano or the harp for me
you know me
i don't even like harp or the piano but
i convinced myself that i like it
because it was a way to flex my money if
i ever got it and then i did and then i
realized that hiring somebody is not
economical and it's also kind of
annoying because they always around
also
i'm [ __ ] a diva and i don't want
anybody that's going to be around i got
to tell us what to do because they might
[ __ ] up and then i get blood red mad so
instead of that i got the piano that
plays itself
you know what i mean when i was younger
i had this vision in my mind that boss
of a boss in a cartoon like duck tales i
wanted to jump in a pool of money
coins but then i realized a little bit
after that that you know what i mean
jumping into a pile of coins you would
absolutely break your [ __ ] neck
whether you're a duck or not
so i thought about hiring a guy to play
the harp even though i don't like harp
music and i thought about playing
hiring a guy to play the piano even
though i don't like piano music
you know i do hip hop
i rap about hoes and money and rims i'm
killing people
so instead of hiring a guy because he
would be so annoying to being at my
house and also i do crazy deviant [ __ ]
and yell at the maids
i will get the i and i like and
basically i'm too lonely to have anybody
about the piano that played itself
[Laughter]
there it is all the way all across the
echoey dining room
with no furniture in it because i ain't
got kids
cause i'm lonely
shout out to all the pair
eh
dude it's so funny to [ __ ] imagine
these guys sleeping
like actually just being in their beds
you know
and waking up a little bit at 6 30 and
being like i bet i could get another
obligation and then and then falls back
to sleep at seven and then wakes up at
[ __ ] 9 30.
[Laughter]
time to wake up and press the button on
the piano
to make the piano play itself
so lonely also so annoying you know
so echoey dude
also rick ross are you fat or not
you're one of those guys that it's like
just gain weight or [ __ ] chop it off
at this point
and then dude it's on hot freestyle the
[ __ ]
instagram handle is hot freestyle
and dude it says rick ross flex is
different
dude that's how did that become so passe
so quick the i'm different [ __ ]
two chainz did it and he was like i'm
different yeah i'm different and
everyone's like oh that's [ __ ] cool
and now everyone will step out of a you
got [ __ ] stepping out of a
tesla and they're just like yo dude i'm
different and you're like nah dude you
got the [ __ ] s model or whatever not
the good one is
hot freestyle and then it says rick ross
living different i mean dude how many
different things on the thing over it
says rick ross flex is different
rick ross and then the caption is rick
ross living different
rick ross is lonely different
and then the [ __ ] [ __ ] on the all the
comments are like god damn bro
[ __ ] yeah
fire emojis
[Music]
merch is off to a good start this year
thanks to ship station with shipstation
you'll never worry about shipping again
make the switch to a solution that
handles all of your shipping needs
quickly affordably and painlessly
shipstation is already trusted by over
100 000 e-commerce sellers okay keep
track of orders from any sales channel
it's very easy you find the best
shipping carrier with deeply discounted
rates
automate just about any shipping task
with just a few clicks
um
my i really like ship station because uh
the happy fans get their merch
and they get it hassle-free they get it
quickly it just is a great way for me to
get my merch out there
it you can save time by funneling all of
your orders into one simple interface no
matter where you're selling
it's great there's no more headaches
from dealing with the returns and the
return tracking shipstation makes it all
easy and you also save money who doesn't
like that you don't want to save money
no you want to save money so use ship
station uh when you compare uh other
carrier options and you choose the best
shipping solution every time with
shipstation uh your small business can
access the same discounted rates usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies okay
so it's not just for the big companies
and just save your sanity with
shipstation you can know your orders uh
are handled and that you're getting the
best rates and it's no wonder that 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business okay
they're that good so get on the ship
station train uh ship more in less time
with shipstation use my offer code
congrats to get a 60-day free trial it's
free for 60 days
with the offer code congrats that's two
months free no hassle stress free
shipping just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in congrats ship
station make ship happen
[Music]
oh man
rick ross [ __ ] flex is different dude
how lonely is rick ross does he have a
wife does rick ross have a wife and kids
i ain't got no kids so i got a so i got
a piano that plays itself
[Laughter]
hell yeah
i ain't got no significant other so what
had happened in my life for me
personally is
at this moment
i got a piano that plays itself
my dude is friends you know
yeah yeah that's true you do have that
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] how annoying is rick ross dude
dude how annoying yo come over let's
smoke cigars and play poker dude doing
all this [ __ ] you know rick ross does
all this [ __ ] that he doesn't even like
doing he just like pretends it because
he's got this idea in his head about how
what a boss is like
he just shows up in a purple [ __ ]
vest with no pants on with his dick all
out whoa rick ross what are you doing yo
that's what the guy from ducktales does
i got a piano that plays himself your
balls are out
that's what scrooge mcduck do why are
you so bruised up i jumped off of the
dining diving board into some coins
how come you have [ __ ] three ducks
around you have you ever seen duck tales
oh
[Laughter]
i got
i got a piano that plays itself in the
tail
ducktales oh
so insecure
and then afterwards the [ __ ] people
leaving rick ross's place that you're
driving with your homie you're just
they're just like god damn rick ross
it's kind of stressful hanging out with
him huh i don't even like the [ __ ] that
we do around him
like he kind of made us get in the pool
it's cold out
do y'all like [ __ ] shooting clay
pigeons man not really to be honest yeah
man i don't even know how why he got
that thing
it's kind of [ __ ] man we ain't hit
none of them
rick ross ain't even hit none of them
either
i like to clay pigeons man
this way we got pictures that fly for
ourselves
god rick ross dude living different it's
also not necessarily good to live
different you know
uh
i did a [ __ ] show this week
people are
you know what the [ __ ] thing is dude
i did a show this week with a [ __ ]
guy i did a show at the improv and he
set it all up and
i got it on and then another comedian
wanted to do the show
and then i feel like the other comedian
just wanted to do the show because
he wanted to see if he could pop in
whenever he wanted
um to do
on a show that i was on just to kind of
[ __ ] flex you know ego [ __ ]
comedians have the weirdest egos and so
i was like okay and so they let me know
that he wanted to do the show and i was
like yeah [ __ ] awesome cool have him
do the show and they're like cool i'll
get up i'll get a time for you and they
told me my time of the show and then
they were asking him when he wanted to
go
and then he he was like i don't know and
so he's like never mind i'm not doing
the show and it's like and then they
call me and they're like he's not doing
the show and i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] if he does the show or not put it
put him on the show put the people on
the show what the [ __ ] do i care
and i realize that they're just asking
me because they were wondering if i have
an ego about it and i'm like bro i don't
give a [ __ ] dude like put anybody on the
show it doesn't matter
you know unless they're gonna [ __ ]
literally [ __ ] shoot me or backstab
me
right
and so
so uh
so i'm like all right and i had to deal
with that whole [ __ ] like phone call i
don't like talk i gotta talk on the
phone to people yeah cool and texting me
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] and like
this whole [ __ ] and it's like
it's like these
this is the word the most annoying thing
is like to be like everyone's got their
[ __ ] like i'm i'm crazy i got my own
[ __ ] we all got our own [ __ ] we're all
trying to fit in this world right
everybody's talking about i live
different you know what i mean
and we're all trying to [ __ ]
live in this world together and go
co-habitat and uh
and like
just like
have your craziness
have it affect the people that at least
have it affect the people that you love
do you know what i'm talking about like
when you're in a [ __ ] like when i'm
in a cafe and somebody walks in and
they're obviously crazy and they're just
like hey science is everywhere do you
like lizards and you gotta like deal
with that you know and it's annoying as
[ __ ] now i understand it's sad because
the guy's brain broke and he's homeless
and he's [ __ ] dirty and like who
knows what happens he's got a drug
problem he's got to suffer from
addiction it sucks but like in that
moment
a guy walks in does that and you're
affected everyone in the coffee shop is
affected and you're like oh for [ __ ]
sake we had to deal with that okay it's
fine we understand right but then
there's people that actually fit in
society and they're not as high of a
grade of a person at as these crazy
people who walk into the coffee shops
and say science is everywhere but they
like affect [ __ ] that you do in your
life right like if you're gonna drop
your car off to somebody to fix it or if
you order an apple pie out of marie
calendars maybe the person you're
ordering it is one of these people and
you got to deal with them and they
affect your life and fine that's okay
you know it's annoying as [ __ ] but it's
like dude
i gotta deal with it in a work situation
okay but then there's people that you
see like every day they're not
necessarily your friends and maybe you
have one or two or three or four or six
people in your life like that especially
if you know a lot of people or you're a
comedian because compete comedians are
[ __ ] not so dude right
and
and you gotta like deal with these
people like i have people like this in
my life like at least my [ __ ] upness
and my craziness at least it affects
only the people i love
my mom my dad i blew up my life but
[ __ ] it affected my mom my dad my
[ __ ]
kristen you know what i mean my brother
the people that i know
[ __ ] very well and know me we all
went through it together but dude if
you're gonna be somebody that like comes
in and just is annoying as [ __ ] around
because you got your own [ __ ] and it's
affecting us and like
it's my fault that you're not gonna talk
to your mom about this [ __ ]
that [ __ ] sucks
am i making sense here like imagine
being like a guy like that like like a
guy walking into a place and you're like
oh here comes [ __ ] johnny black cloud
i don't know what goddamn mood he's
gonna be in
it's like go [ __ ] talk to your
goddamn brother or some [ __ ]
but now i got we all got to deal with
this black cloud because you're the guy
in the bad mood and weird and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
deal with it on yourself go to [ __ ]
therapy i do a [ __ ] choke load of
therapy
do you know what i mean
and it's just like dude
these people dude
like you know you go i saw it the other
day i saw somebody deal with it they
were at a [ __ ] place ordering a drink
and the person was like what do you want
it's broken the system and the guy and
i'm just like oh [ __ ] dude talk
to your husband
do the job
talk to your husband
i understand it can't always be like
that and every now and then you're gonna
have [ __ ] weird moments but it's like
dude these people who are just like
energy suckers or time wasters get them
out of your life but you can't even get
them all the way out of your life
because they're just there right it's
like falling in love you don't even mean
to sometimes and you don't even want to
sometimes but you meet somebody and
guess what it's just there it happens
because they're around and they're nice
and they smell good
that's what these people are only
they're the [ __ ] dark side of it
god dude figure your [ __ ] out man i
don't even give a [ __ ] about ego stuff
it's like
god comedians are so weird man they're
so [ __ ] weird
and a lot of you know here's what i
think that they're weird because they're
weird is because a lot of these
comedians this is who they are to their
core being like this is what they hung
on to a lot of them were [ __ ] dorks
and [ __ ] like you see them all in the
[ __ ] alt club they're all [ __ ]
they're performing at like a sex shop or
a [ __ ] back of an ikea and they're
like this is the fun show
all them like button down [ __ ]
argyle sweaters and [ __ ] or some pants
that are like too [ __ ] thick for
their stick legs and they're just like
ah so you know well the [ __ ]
political [ __ ] this and that or hey
what wolverine issue [ __ ] 25 you ever
notice and it's like jesus christ dude
dude
how fringe can you be
like just be [ __ ] funny you know and
these [ __ ] but it's their identity
dude it's their [ __ ] identity you
know it's like i gotta wear the glasses
and the [ __ ] thing and we gotta we
gotta [ __ ] up a goddamn you know
uh
side room in a [ __ ]
comic book store we gotta [ __ ] up a side
room at a comic book store and do our
comedy
and it's like this is their identity
dude because they were [ __ ]
losers and this is how they became
someone and i don't even knock wanting
to become someone
but dude like when you're this person
and you're hanging on to comedy as who
you are
and you're like [ __ ] all that [ __ ] i'm
not that person dude i'm not a comedian
[ __ ] that dude and then you get your
little community and [ __ ]
and it's like and it's like like when i
was coming up people were like oh yeah
oh the six two dude with the long hair
and the scruff he thinks he's funny
[ __ ] yeah dude
i'm just trying to chill have a good
[ __ ] time and do some [ __ ] silly
[ __ ] oh and by the way i don't oh yeah
oh he doesn't oh he doesn't have real
jokes yeah i [ __ ] jokes jokes be cornier
than a [ __ ] dude
jokes be cornier than a [ __ ]
you understand
why don't you get up there and just well
what did the [ __ ] parrot say to the
[ __ ] black
and wakka wakka dude jokes be cornier
than a [ __ ] say it near a
[ __ ] washing machine at a laundromat
with your goddamn argyle sweater on
oh but he screams a lot and that's funny
yeah to me
and i'll [ __ ] lay it down dude all
right but i'm not a comedian
i'm a person
i don't give a [ __ ] about this
it's like dude you go in and then you
it
it's like there's so the comedians are
insane dude
i didn't become a comedian for any other
reason that i like to [ __ ] [ __ ]
around and make people laugh
that's it
god but these guys that are just like
it's just so lame dude
he's
[ __ ] you know writers or whatever the
[ __ ]
all right dude jump around do a [ __ ]
say a thing
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't know what
does it matter
i'm a different kind of person
i got the piano that played itself
just wanted to [ __ ] get get to that
line so badly you know
i got the piano that played itself like
just say it in a rap song you [ __ ]
loser
rick ross you're good though you make
good music
i saw have you ever seen an ad that's so
confusing
that i literally didn't know have you
ever seen
these [ __ ] super bowl commercials
they're just they're not that good dude
there's maybe one good one a super bowl
and how annoying is it the person who
thinks they have a personality that's
like you know i only watch the super
bowl for the commercials oh really dude
here's the nobel peace prize
oh yeah man cool you're just dripping
with personality hey i'd love to sit and
chat you with you for three hours oh you
watch the super bowl because of the oh
how quirky dude
are you like watching [ __ ] bud light
commercials you boring piece of [ __ ]
oh which commercial did you like the one
that [ __ ] starred gary oldman at the
end or the one with 9 000 horses doing
some [ __ ] for budweiser dude it's a
[ __ ] commer the budweiser commercials
are forget you're not curing cancer
from the very depths of who we are you
know what i mean
get shit-faced this it's like dude it's
beer
saving lives one soul at a time
and then gary oldman coming like you
know they'll get some like high-profile
[ __ ] actor that like where you're
like not even it's not even like bruce
willis it's like what the [ __ ] is this
guy doing a commercial for you know what
i mean they'll get like daniel day lewis
in a kleenex commercial
you don't even know again dan diluz is
such a good actor you don't even know
what his voice even sounds like and
he'll be in like some [ __ ] jerky
he'll be in some jerky [ __ ] like uh
carfax commercial we're like wow carfax
has that much money i who knew
and daniel de lewis would be like show
me the carfax
um
just covered in blood
but yeah dude i saw an ad already by the
way that confused
where you ever see an ad and you're just
like is this a movie or not
i wat it was on first of all i'm on
instagram i'm looking at instagram bmw
po i don't follow bmw or no maybe i do i
don't know either way you know how [ __ ]
pops up you don't even follow it
you're just like scrolling instagram and
something will pop up and it'll be like
hardwood floors what the [ __ ] i don't
follow hardwood floors well that's kind
of a nice floor or maybe i'll get a
floor one day and then you go and you
see some [ __ ] hoe
just with no parents
that never was raised right with just
tits out holding the watch up like look
at my watch and you're like okay but
cleavage
and um
and i scroll i keep scrolling i see bmw
posts a picture with [ __ ] um
what's her name salma hayek
and it says uh
like whatever her it's like a
a [ __ ] greek mythology picture of her
like this and it's got like all this
like
like her greek name like hermes like
she's playing a character let's say
herman i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but
and then i scroll to the right and it
shows like another like a building with
like lightning coming out and and it's
got arnold schwarzenegger
and he's holding a sword and he's got
like a gray beard and he's got like
[ __ ] and it's a zeus
and i'm like k
and then you scroll through a third page
and it's like another actor i've never
seen but he's like they're pretending
he's famous or something maybe he's
famous in like england
and he's like and he's playing like
another guy
and it's like got lightning everywhere
and on the bmw thing it's like electric
meets [ __ ] thing
electric what the [ __ ] i'm gonna just
gonna look at this be and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
is this a movie coming out or what so
look at arnold schwarzenegger's [ __ ]
page here it is hera that's who she's
playing
and it's it says sam hayek penalt hera
arnold schwarzenegger zeus
rafe moeller poseidon
and it says coming soon the caption
the ultimate electric performance and
that's it
and i'm like okay
but is it a [ __ ] movie
so then i go to
some hayek's page and she posts it so
i'm like oh she's they're doing a movie
and bmw is like partnering they're
making a movie
and then i go to arnold schwarzenegger's
[ __ ] and he posted so i'm like oh this
is a new schwarzenegger movie [ __ ] yeah
and dude they're just advertising a
commercial that's coming out on the
super bowl
they're advertising
advertisement on advertisement
like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this is the inception
of and it's like okay oh so they're just
it's an electric car and arnold
schwarzenegger oh so it's an electric
car and argel schwarzenegger is playing
zeus in it
but you're like what who the [ __ ] are
they they
the money dude
honor schwarzenegger just holly how
they're all driving around i'm zeus how
the hell are y'all
holly the super bowl i'm zeus
okay
how crazy is the [ __ ] world you know
it's happened like two times where i
thought an ad was a movie
don't do it have your ad be your ad and
have the movie be a movie
or bmw make a whole [ __ ] movie make a
whole movie about it why don't you just
make a whole movie about it why don't
you just have bmw bmw the movie
and just make it like [ __ ] put arnold
schwarzenegger in it put some hike in it
put him in it make him zeus call him
zeus in it who gives a [ __ ] it'll be big
make it bad who cares
make it bad make it [ __ ] bad make it
in one room make arnold schwarzenegger
in one and a half hours in a
one-and-a-half hour movie with somebody
i can honestly just like i'm zeus
and some hayek is in some like revealing
[ __ ] and he's like i have a lightning
you know how good that would do for bmw
are you [ __ ] kidding me
um
i never brought this up i got this
tattoo you know
and because i was talking about this the
other night and i was like did uh and
some and we were talking about somebody
said do you tip
somebody was asking me
linoche was asking me do you tip
something for something and i was like
no
like it was so obviously something that
you don't tip for it was like so weird
it was like he was like do you tip if
like you buy a backpack at [ __ ] uh
you know what i mean at north face like
and i'm just like huh
stuff is just what it costs
and um
and then and then i was like dude
no i was like you tip if it's like
a servant like a waiter or a waitress or
like a a ride or or like pizza delivery
but like the [ __ ]
the tipping thing is annoying like i tip
well because
i want you know i understand it's hard
out there and i want people to do well i
tip well but like
i live in america but like europe they
don't tip dude they're just like it
costs what i [ __ ] cost huh
uh it cause it costs but you're saying
in america it's extra
just tell me how much it is i'll pay
that
it's five dollars well all right it's
five dollars would you like to tip more
tell me how much it is and that's that
right and they're right that's it that
is what it should be this whole tipping
thing is [ __ ] up so but i tip and i
tip well
and my whole thing is like dude
just
it's for the it's for that it's for
rides pizza
uh
uh waiters and waitresses
and then like
he was like what about like uh bathroom
attendance and it's like dude
that's the most annoying one because you
they alway you always feel like you
should because they're just standing in
a bathroom and you're just like ah you
want to give them money and be like
get out of the bathroom one day you know
like that's what you're like here's
here's a few bucks get
get into a place that doesn't have piss
all over a little bit more you know
it's like it's weird and sad and and
they're always like doing crazy cool
[ __ ] with the towels because they're
there for eight hours you know
you just piss you still got your [ __ ]
out and they're just like towel and
you're like all right why are you in a
tux
what kind of [ __ ] weirdo hands people
with their genitals out dollar bills
while you're in a tux
just [ __ ]
towel and you're like here you go
and then you don't have money a lot and
you're like sorry i don't have
and they're like no there was a nicest
motherf how are they nice they're
standing in a bathroom for seven hours
and they're always like oh that's okay i
have a god
god bless you i hope you win the [ __ ]
lottery i hope you're driving you a urus
you're just like all right cool that
guy's happy as [ __ ] you know happier to
me
and so but that's annoying because it's
like i just want to piss and it's not
even that i don't want to give people my
money i don't want to have to [ __ ]
like do extra [ __ ] when i'm in the
bathroom i don't want it to take any
longer than it takes
i just took a [ __ ] hot [ __ ] and like
i got to be like oh oh sorry sir we're
both smelling it you know
sorry here here's two dollar here's two
dollars here's three dollars
nice tux
water splattering everywhere
it's like a [ __ ]
you know
whatever people probably like we're just
trying to make a book i know it is and i
do give those guys money unless i don't
have [ __ ] dollar bills on me but
the weirdest one was dude i got i get
tattoo
like
tattoos
and like i guess i didn't know you're
supposed to tip your tattoo artist
and they're cause they're like what
about haircuts my friends and i was like
no you tip haircuts because they work
for a [ __ ] they have to pay a chair
fee and [ __ ] like that but dude the
tattoo i got it's just like
i go to the tattoo guys i've gotten
tattoos from a couple different guys and
like they [ __ ]
i say how much is it going to be and
they say around this
and then so they can say anything and so
i say okay and then i get there and then
when they finish like the last tattoo i
got the guy was like
i was like okay so what i owe you and he
was like uh
uh for 400 bucks like that's how he said
it so i was like okay so i gave him 400
bucks
and i drove home
and my [ __ ] nanny and uh kristen were
like how much was it i told him and like
would you tip him and i was like huh
they're like would you tip him and i was
like i don't know he just told me it was
400 bucks so i just gave him 400 bucks
they were like you have to tip tattoo
artists i was like he just made up the
[ __ ] price
like just tell me the price
it's just he's just chilling in a place
it's not like he's got a [ __ ] pace of
yeah he pays rent in the place but
everyone pays rent i was like just i pay
i [ __ ] paypal them as a friend
it's not like he even needs to pay taxes
on it
and dude i asked him how much he's like
i don't know i guess four give me 400
so i give him 500.
then it's like this weird thing where
it's like so so it's like so i'm giving
him more than that so i'm like oh no
you're wrong on your own price [ __ ] that
i'm giving you this which i guess is
better for him anyway because he's
making more money but then
they [ __ ] made me feel so bad when i
got home that i [ __ ] paypaled him
more money just and i didn't say
anything about it
i just gave it i gave him another
hundred dollars
and then he never texted me or anything
or wrote me again and i'm like that's
fine at least he got it he's got to know
what it's for and then and then and then
like
month later i i wrote to
i [ __ ] wrote an email to his
assistant i was like hey man i'd love to
come in again they're like oh yeah we're
booked all the way up until this we
haven't come up with more dates and i'm
like did i [ __ ] up i gotta go to a whole
new artist now
just tell me how much this shit's worth
well tell me what i need to give you
don't don't give me the fake price and
then i gotta guess the real price with
the tip
it's so weird to tip a tattoo artist
dude just tell me more
it's happened to all the tattoo artists
i've gotten they say like it's this much
money and then i give them that much
money and then the assistant on the
first assistant was like if you want to
give him a tip and give him a tip and
i'm just like we're just in his house
this is so weird
600 but actually
700.
what's this fake price you're running
with
like if you're paying 600 you're paying
seven you pay 700.
i got the piano to play the self
rick ross dude let's go to this
throwback
[Music]
nope i eat pears now and [ __ ] like that
wow
dude
the [ __ ] energy of when he says pears
i eat pears now and [ __ ] like that gonna
cry
shout out to all the pear scentsy
out of breath wow the way he pears now
and [ __ ] like that gonna cry yeah shout
out to all the pear
shot of breath
like that
shout out to the pair
a [ __ ] old man
hate pears
professor terence towel no
nope
don't like when that happens dude
[ __ ] yeah dude when youtube keeps it
moving i don't like that dude
i want to do what i want to do and
that's it dude here we go let's play it
again i love it
i eat pears now and [ __ ] like that
shout out to all the pear
the shortest clip of all time to it
he pears and [ __ ] like that dude and he
goes like this and then he gets cincy he
gets sunc he gets ah insecure hanging it
out that he's like i guess i'll do a
wiggle
he left it out there for too long and it
was like
shout out to pear and [ __ ] like that
wow how much would joe biden do the
exact same thing
for real
wait
shut up
one of the greatest clips of all time oh
[ __ ] it didn't do it again god damn it
one of the greatest clips of all time
i pair and [ __ ]
i can't believe how much he's gonna cry
i eat pears now and [ __ ] like that
shout out to all the pair fancy how
about the other guy wow i never realized
it dude he's doing the thing where he's
[ __ ] like
that's don't do it 101 on interviewing
that's interviewing 101 do it just
holding the mic
waiting for gold and just
oh au pair
wow dude so [ __ ] the other guy said
that's probably why i was gonna cry
because the guy was so [ __ ] how much is
that bill nye pairs now and [ __ ] like
that wow look at him shout out to all
the pair oh oh wow dude
a velociraptor that guy with his mouth
open
like that
shout out to oliver
i got the piano to this self wow how
sad you know just chill just do stuff
regular
billionaire um
dude this was awesome the dave grohl
thing
the dave grohl thing this is
when i tell you i aspire to be this
i [ __ ] howled at this
everything through and through
this
whole thing is the most
cheat up from the feed up thing
i think i
i think one of the most
awesome celebrity things i've seen in a
i mean i would say
definitely since the coronavirus i mean
i would say probably
in the two
you'd be hard-pressed to find something
so
ill to do as a celebrity
in the past [ __ ] decade i will say
that i'll go on record to say this the
[ __ ] if you're talking about video
like there's something there's been some
great like funny weird stupid tweets and
[ __ ] like the richard carnes thing like
about how he said i've been thinking
about doing nfts but i'm not going to do
it like there's been some great moments
but this [ __ ] dude
all of it from the beginning
let's see one thing i'm gonna say
just starting i'm gonna say it one more
time talking to them like a school
teacher unbelievable
one thing i'm gonna say one more time
talking to a group of people
who are just holding pictures of him you
know
so worshipping him and um
and he's already at the near end of his
rope but this is the near end of his
rope as dave grohl gets because he is by
all accounts i've always heard one of
the nicest dudes in the world okay i saw
him at the comedy store once and he was
literally the whole time just watching
everyone like this
like just the nicest guy okay
one thing i'm gonna say it one more time
and he double down
he made he made it softer unbelievable
internalized his anger and didn't lash
out so many guys would be like i'm gonna
say this one more time but you're gonna
i'm gonna say it one more time but he
[ __ ]
breathed it in
and then just
i'm going to say it one more time like
he's hypnotizing you i mean that is so
already that's cheetah okay but is it
cheat up from the feed up let's see
one thing i'm gonna say one more time
one thing
mother teresa so now he secretly
handed you
he secretly handed these people who are
trying to make quick dollars off of dave
grohl's signature
handfuls of [ __ ]
and he's saying
you are this
right because i only signed for charity
so now what are you going to say you now
what are you going to say
you're going to still want a signature
and you're going to take money at a
charity's mouth
here handing you [ __ ]
you are this guys
there's enough to go around
okay so that's amazing that he did that
in a very soft spoken voice
unless it's for charity okay can we
donate something can you donate you said
that new york signed in dc the next day
that's it oh that guy's such a [ __ ] you
said that new york and then you signed
in dc the next day such a tattletale
dude
such a tattletale dude don't be that guy
right oh you said you said you said
don't be that [ __ ] guy
now let's see what he goes on to this is
the best what he goes on to from detroit
this is what makes him the true g i'm
gonna say one more time
one thing
i'm gonna say one more time unbelievable
school teacher
i stopped signing [ __ ] unless it's for
charity okay can we donate something can
you donate you said that new york and
then signed in dc the next day that's it
here we go here we go all right best
part you can write my son's name on it
where's the other thing
see ya
come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
here's the other thing he was he was
actually searching for something to say
i know it dude he was getting ready to
say something else and then realize no
matter what i do it's gonna be so stupid
this isn't gonna end well and then he
[ __ ] jutted his elbows out
like a marionette and said see ya and
[ __ ] turn on a dime and ran into his
suv where he's getting driven by
jeet up from the feed up award goes to
dave roll dude that is so unreal
here's the other thing see ya
dude so [ __ ] good wow dude i only
signed [ __ ] i stopped signing [ __ ]
unless it's for charity and here's the
other thing
see ya dude that is so
how did he do that that's like bad
acting in real life like in a movie
you'd be like ah come on you could have
done it better but this guy killed it in
real life dude we weren't gonna do it
but
[Music]
dave grohl just killing it dude one fire
just sent me this one ringo ringo doing
it doing a different thing like that
maybe
this is a serious message to everybody
watching my
update right now on song
on so many quaaludes on so many
quaaludes
saying so many words has no idea what's
going to say this is a serious message
to everybody watching my
peace and love not even his hand i want
to tell you
please
after the 20th of october do not send
fan mail to any address that you have
nothing will be signed after the 20th of
october oh wow if that has a date i'm
gonna envelope it's gonna be tossed i'm
gonna do this i'm warning you with peace
and love i have too much to
do no more fan mail thank you thank you
no objects to be signed nothing
uh anyway peace love peace and love
i'm warning you with peace and love he
said
can't warn someone with peace and love
won't work
i'll hug you
dude
unbelievable that is unbelievable wow
that is so good dude the egos i gotta
i'm doing that i'm gonna put that out i
am warning you with peace and love i
will not be signing anything up i like
how he gave himself a date like if
you've got your lasting if you're about
to send it in hopefully you get it done
today because after this
after and also this was obviously done
in the 80s where was this put out there
was no social media
like
even if even if there was social media
even if you did it now people would
still send it in because they'd be like
oh i didn't see that where was he
[ __ ] sending vhs's to his fans houses
i'm warning you with peace and love it
will do not send objects to sign the
fact that he thought he had to do this
and not just not sign stuff is on
[ __ ] real dude that is so good
lucy in the sky
with diamonds
oh wow dude i will watch that again
uh i mean starts in eh
close on his eyes and zooms out to his
face why
wanted to make it artistic this is a
serious message seriously everybody
watching my
update right now peace and love peace
and love
i want to tell you
please
of october do not send fan mail to any
address
that you have nothing will be signed
after the 20th of october oh my if that
has a date on the envelope it's going to
be tossed i'm warning you with peace and
love but i have too much to do so no
more fan mail thank you thank you dude
this was in 2008
what the [ __ ] camera was he using he
posted this in 2008 was this his first
tweet they didn't have video back then
on twitter
wow dude i've just posted it on [ __ ]
ringo starr's youtube page
finally social media like that was what
he was now i can get my message out i
don't have to sign anything anymore
get the camera ready let's post this now
that there's a youtube
oh my god dude
we gotta [ __ ] get to that i'm gonna
do that i'm gonna do that
i'm not signing anything anymore i
signed something the other day i sent a
lot of stuff the other day actually i'm
done
um
i guess we're good right
um listen guys we got the new merch
don't push me dude
right
don't make it easy for me to just move
on don't nudge me
wear that eagle proud dude
let him know
stand your [ __ ] spot stand in
your spot dude that's yours
um
and then brea
california go to chrisleya.com irvine
california go to chrisleya.com i got
shows coming up check the website i
might add more by the time this comes
out who knows but um hey guys that's the
episode for today if you want to catch
the rest of the episode uncut no
commercials no ads no nothing uh and
extra footage and uh extra
bits or whatever you want to call it uh
on
patreon.com go over to
patreon.comcrystalia
support the show it really helps us keep
this uh show going uh it's six bucks a
month and you get uh behind the scenes
of
um what do you call it the videos i do
my vlogs there's extra content and
there's other things that we do as well
and we have a discord that we chat on so
come on over to
patreon.comcrystalia thanks a lot
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
you have a fuzzy on your mustache